فنلندا العضو الاحدث في حلف شمال الاطلسي
تدير وتستضيف احدث الاستفزازات للجاره
الروسيه فسلاح الجو الفنلندي اعلن عن بدء
عمليه تحدي القطب الشمالي والتي تستمر
اسبوعين واصفا اياها باكبر مناورات تنظم
حتى الان هذه المناورات تنظمها الدول
الاسكندنافيه كل سنتين منذ عشر سنوات وتضم
اربع عشره دوله هذه المره 12 عضوا بنيتو
بالاضافه للسويد وسويسرا التدريبات واسعه
النطاق تشمل نحو 150 طائره مقاتله من دول
غربيه بينها الولايات المتحده بريطانيا
وفرنسا وستتمركز الطائرات في شمال النرويج
والسويد وفنلندا وكذلك في قاعده بيركال
تمبير الفنلنديه تتزامى المناورات مع
اجتماع لوزاره خارجيه الحلف في اوسلو هذا
الاسبوع وكذلك زياره لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الى فنلندا بعد يومين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات